since news of the new coronavirus first
emerged in January 2020 doctors around
the world have thought of it as a
disease of the lungs but a flood of new
reports describing damage to the heart
blood vessels guts kidneys brain and
even fingers and toes suggest that kovat
19 is a disease of the entire body this
is how it begins its journey and
ultimately does its damage the virus
Tsarskoe v2 typically enters through the
mouth or the nose using its protein
spike it latches onto a cell surface
receptor called angiotensin converting
enzyme 2 or ace 2
once inside the cell the virus can make
many copies of itself if the immune
system can't fight off the virus in
these early stages it moves down the
windpipe and into the lungs there the
virus seeks out cells rich in ace to
receptors and air sacs known as alveoli
which transfer oxygen to tiny blood
vessels that's circulated to the rest of
the body as immune cells rush in to halt
the invasion a mixture of fluids and
dead cells are left behind from the
battle they clog the delicate air sacs
making breathing even harder damage can
be extensive in this 3d model yellow
regions indicate scarred lung tissue in
a 59 year old man who later died of
kovat 19 doctors can also see this
destruction using x-rays ravaged lung
tissue appears white in places where
there should be black spaces of air from
the lungs the virus continues its
journey in critical cases it can enter
the bloodstream where it binds to ace to
receptors on cells lining the vessels
this can trigger body-wide inflammation
and blood clots which in turn can cause
heart attacks pulmonary embolisms
strokes and even damage to tiny blood
vessels in the fingers and toes
in the rest of the body the virus can
wreak havoc too in the heart tissues may
swell the heart rhythm may alter and the
weakened muscle may fail to pump enough
blood to the rest of the body in the
liver damage can result from an immune
system in overdrive and from the very
drugs patients are taking to stem the
disease in the kidneys even more
extensive harm could come from a direct
viral attack or from a whole-body event
like plummeting blood pressure but there
are two other odd places where damage is
showing up the intestines and the brain
the lower digestive tract is rich in ace
to receptors and many patients up to 50%
in some studies have diarrhea viral RNA
has also been found in many stool
samples a few labs have reported finding
whole live viruses not just snippets of
viral genetic code in feces but there's
not yet firm evidence that the virus
could spread this way scientists do have
a theory of how the virus could travel
to the brain from the nose and then
upward through the olfactory bulb which
connects to the brain this route could
explain the puzzling loss of smell
experienced by some patients in the
meantime doctors are seeing a multitude
of issues in the brains of some patients
including strokes seizures confusion and
inflammation and especially in the
sickest patients doctors can see
inflammation in the conjunctiva the
membrane that lines the front of the eye
and inner eyelid
the most troubling thing for researchers
now is that while they know what damage
is taking place they don't always know
why better understanding the pathology
of Cova 19 is already changing treatment
options like the usage of
anti-inflammatory drugs and blood
thinners as more details come into focus
clinicians can tailor treatments that
they hope will save lives